去年刚结婚，
然后我们是相亲认识的，
然后认识了一年，
我的话今年是27岁，
他的话是30岁，
结婚几个月之后，
我发现他就就是欠有外债20万，
然后他婚前就是也没有告诉我，
然后我知道了，
就是非常生气，
为啥欠20万，
是因为给财产欠20万，
还是因为呃太少是二是吧，
是就是因为他之前做的那个工作，
就是之前他自己做那个物流的工作，
然后做了应该有三年两三年吧，
然后就欠了这么多钱，
他是老板吗？
还是怎么的，
对，
然后就是请了有两个人吧，
然后一个文员，
然后一个给他就是开车的，
你发现他欠了20万，
然后他说是以前做物流的时候欠下的，
然后现在他是一个什么态度呢？
就是一直在亏损的状态嘛，
然后他今年我们结婚了，
他就没做了，
然后现在就是去给别人打工，
然后也是做物流，
就是一个月就是8000多到9000的样子吧，
然后他现在自己的话就是在慢慢的还好，
那你是做什么工作的吗？
我刚开始我不知道这个事情嘛，
然后我知道他欠了这么多钱之后。
然后我也开始摆烂了，
然后今年的话，
我就没有上班，
你发现他欠债，
然后你还摆烂不上班，
对不起啊，
我我丽姐，
我真的啊，
我不理不能理解你，
你发现他欠债，
如果你不能接受好，
咱俩就一拍两散，
如果你能接受好，
咱俩就拧成一股绳，
咱俩一起努力把这个欠债还完了，
我认为这两个选项才是我能够预料得到的选项，
而你你发现他欠了20万，
你就开始百万不上班，
你百万不上班想表达什么意思呢？
就是说我也不上班了，
你然后现在你是你不想帮他还，
因为他之前欠的那些债不完全是就是因为工作的，
他就是乱七八糟的的，
然后欠了这么多啊好，
那那你想问我会几的问题是啥哦，
我觉得他们之前就没有一经改，
都没有透露这个消息给我，
然后就是什么时候发现在什么时候发现的的，
就是我看他手机，
看他手机有那个还款的那个记录嘛，
就是催他还款的那个信用的啊。
他一直都没打算告诉我的，
我觉得然后是我自己看到的，
然后他就实在瞒不住，
然后现在的话，
他爸妈好像也没有给他还，
然后他自己现现在一个月8000多的工资，
一个月根本生活也都还不够，
也还不了多少，
然后我现在就是想问你，
我要不要帮他一起还，
他对你好吗？
嗯，
我觉得还好吧，
家务谁干啊，
家务没什么家务，
家务的话我干吧，
这是啊，
你们两口子有房吗？
没房，
现在租房一个月花多少钱呀？
一个月应该就八九百吧，
这边房租比较便宜，
那现在家里面的开销都是男方来承担，
那他跟你结婚的时候有给你彩礼钱吗？
给了，
然后彩礼钱我是存钱，
那给了多少彩礼啊，
呃，
18万，
然后我到手的话是12万八，
那剩下那个钱在你爸妈那是吗？
但是我这我存认好了，
就是他总共给了18万，
然后你说你到手是12万八，
那还还有几万块钱的，
那几万块钱在哪呀？
那都是办了酒，
办了酒席啊，
你用他给你的彩礼在你妈这边办酒席是不是对办了酒席和陪嫁那些。
啊，
办了酒席和陪嫁那些啊，
男方父母是干啥的呀，
都是普通的工人，
也是50岁了吧，
然后他还有一个妹妹是18岁，
就是没有上学的，
今年刚出来工作哦，
那你接头呢，
我这头就是我是最小的，
然后我哥哥已经有孩子了，
那你以前自己是干啥工作的呀，
以前我就是就是做那个案场客服吧，
就是那些卖房的那个销售的那种哦，
那以前你自己做那个客服大概一年能挣多少钱呀？
一个月的话就是5000多吧，
那你自己在婚前有攒下来什么存款吗？
嗯，
没多少，
这就是说嗯，
我觉得呃，
你要不要替他去还这个婚前的这个债务呢？
其实是取决于就是你自己用心去感受，
呃这个老公对你好不好，
心不心疼你是不是呃踏踏实实跟你过日子，
然后她现在在外面工作，
他的工作能力怎么样，
有没有这个前途，
有没有发展，
如果他说一直一个月挣八千九千块钱，
你这头找工作挣5000块钱啊，
你们在当地能不能维持一个相对比较稳定的幸福的这样一个生活标准，
这些你自己衡量一下，
你肯定虽然不工作，
你肯定这个路子是不对的，
嗯，
我明年我就打算去工作了啊，
那你就自己去工作一段时间吧，
我还有一个就是就是刚结婚那几天，
结婚才三四天，
那时候我还不知道他借钱啊，
然后他自己也没说，
然后他那时候就要找我拿彩，
拿彩礼钱哦，
你没给他说没给，
他也算是挺清醒啊，
对我没给他，
他她妈妈的耳朵有点不好，
就是他他女儿现在18岁嘛，
他妹就是因为生他妹妹的时候，
然后就导。
这耳朵一边耳朵有点那个了，
就是现在我想问你问一下姐姐，
你就是我要不要主张去说带他妈妈去医院把这个耳朵看好，
我觉得这个事情是这样子的啊，
嗯，
你自己有能力的时候对吧，
你自己很有能力的时候，
你去说带婆婆把耳朵去看一下，
我觉得这个是你善良的表现是吧，
但是你你现在你自己说实在话啊，
我说难听点的话好不好，
你自己一天挣挣不挣5000块钱完了之后，
你现在跟你老公关系又不是很稳定是吧，
你跟他能不能过到你他还不好说呢，
人家要跟你分手了，
还得要你退彩礼，
你自己你有你有这个能力去给他妈妈花这个钱治这个病吗？
因为我觉得他这个耳朵不好，
就是太麻烦了，
老是说话要跟他说很大声很大声，
有时候他也听不到我话，
只只能点到这儿了，
第一，
你俩夫妻关系不是很稳定，
对，
人家到时候跟你这么开的时候是要你退彩礼的，
第三，
你自己一个月挣5000块钱，
你哪里来的这个实力和能力去治疗他你婆婆的耳朵呢？
那如果他爸爸说去看的话，
然后我就陪着他们去看就行了啊，
没必要啊，
人家人家有老公，
有儿子有女儿，
哪轮得着你啊，
有些事情哦，
啊，
咱有帮什么当家的，
家里面所有钥匙都归你，
所有钱都归你了，
没必要让后面决定对不对？
嗯，
好吧，
我就不说这些了，
嗯，
哎，
好吧，
好，
那就这样啊。